[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin guten Abend zusammen es
war eine durchwachsene Bilanz der
deutschen champions league teams dazu
später mehr mit dir deinen Konsequenzen
guten Abend und wir blicken jetzt
gemeinsam auf die wichtigsten Themen des
Tages
wer bezahlt den doppelwumms die Kritik
am ergebnislosen bund-ländertreffen
wächst
Putin unterzeichnet annexionsgesetz
während die Ukraine weitere Gebiete
zurückerobern kann
und Rücktrittsforderungen nach
aartalvideo hubschrauberaufnahmen aus
der flutnacht erhöhen den Druck auf den
Innenminister von Rheinland-Pfalz
[Musik]
lange geredet nichts erreicht die Bund
länderverhandlungen zu Entlastung in der
Energiekrise sind mehr oder weniger
ergebnislos vertagt worden und darum
hagelt es Kritik aus der Wirtschaft und
Opposition während einige
Ministerpräsidenten mehr Unterstützung
vom Bund fordern verlangt Finanzminister
Lindner von den Ländern mehr
Kompromissbereitschaft Diana Zimmermann
berichtet
angespannte Minen im Kabinett wenn die
Regierung erwartet hatte dass ihr 200
Milliarden Euro breiter Rettungsschirm
anhaltende Erleichterung auslösen würde
so sah sie sich getäuscht sechs Tage
nach der Ankündigung des riesigen Pakets
nennt die Opposition den doppelwumms mal
eine Wundertüte mal ein Würstchen
es dauert alles viel zu lange wir haben
ja als Länder in der letzten Woche
zusammengesessen und ziemlich klar
gesagt was kommen muss auch weil wir mit
den Kommunen weil wir mit der Wirtschaft
gesprochen haben weil wir ganz nah an
den Bürgern sind und die Menschen
verlieren die Nerven die Unternehmen
wissen nicht mehr wie es weitergeht es
dauert einfach zu lang
gestern hatten Kanzler und
Ministerpräsidenten zwar getagt nicht
aber entschieden wer was bezahlt auch
Stefan weil würde seinen Bürgern lieber
klare Zusagen statt Rosen schenken der
SPD-Mann kämpft darum am Sonntag
landesschef in Niedersachsen zu bleiben
und hätte Rückenwind brauchen können
stattdessen wirbt der um Verständnis das
ist nicht so trivial weil eben eine
energiepreisdeckel zu entwerfen der
wirksam ist und der in der Praxis
funktioniert an dieser Stelle müssen wir
tatsächlich auch sicher sein dass die
Vorschläge dann auch anschließend in der
Praxis sich bewähren
nach der gescheiterten gasumlage will
die Regierung für eine gute
gaspreisbremse nicht nur die Vorschläge
der am Wochenende tagenden
Expertenkommission sondern auch noch die
Steuerschätzung Ende Oktober Abwarten
auf der Grundlage kann es danach erst
eine konkrete finanzielle Verabredung
zwischen Bund und Ländern geben das ist
eine Normalität und insofern werden wir
schnell und auch rechtzeitig für das
nächste Jahr die notwendigen
Entscheidungen getroffen haben im Inland
heißt es zu langsam im Ausland ganz
falsch von seinen EU-Kollegen wurde
Lindner dafür kritisiert dass
Deutschland mit seinem Alleingang den
Wettbewerb verzerrre und die Inflation
in der Eurozone anheizen vor allem
weniger wohlhabende Länder fordern
EU-weite Hilfsmaßnahmen
obwohl die Zeit drängt theocall in
Berlin und viele die Krise längst spüren
finden bunt und Länder bei den
entlastungsplänen nicht zusammen ist das
Pokern oder Ratlosigkeit also ich
fürchte das ist beides und das macht es
für die betroffenen Bürger wahrlich
nicht besser gepokert wird ja auf beiden
Seiten die Länder wollen den neuen 200
Milliarden Topf des Bundes nutzen um
sich von einigen Zusatzbelastungen die
in die Krise und die Koalition
aufgebürdet haben zu befreien und der
Bund verweist darauf dass die Länder
finanziell längst ist viel bessere Blatt
in der Hand haben und es jetzt reicht
mit den Bundeshilfen die Ratlosigkeit
allerdings die bürdet der Bund den
Bürgern auf und das noch wochenlang erst
verkündet die Ampel ja den 200
Milliarden Abwehrschirm spannt ihn dann
aber nicht auf und das obwohl ja Bürger
und Unternehmen zunehmend im Regen Ihrer
Rechnungen stehen strategisch war das
gestern ein Desaster mit Ansage wenn
schon vorher klar ist dass man erst den
Wochen so weit ist den gaspreisdeckel zu
präsentieren
dann darf man sich nicht wundern wenn
das Publikum nachher ruft die Konferenz
oder wahlweise die Koalition ist nackt
danke für die Einschätzung nach Berlin
Theo Paul wie kann Europa unabhängiger
von russischen Gaslieferungen werden
auch darum geht es bei den
deutsch-spanischen
Regierungskonsultationen Kanzler Scholz
ist dazu mit mehreren
Kabinettsmitgliedern nach La Coruna
geflogen wo sie von Regierungschef
Sanchez empfangen wurden beide Länder
wollen die mit Cut Pipeline nach
Frankreich fertig bauen so könnte Gas
von lng-terminals in Spanien nach
zentral Europa gelangen
zum Krieg in der Ukraine Kiew meldet
russische Angriffe zugleich aber neue
Rückeroberungen in Regionen die Moskau
für annektiert erklärt wegen der
völkerrechtswidrigen Annexionen bringen
die EU-Staaten jetzt das inzwischen
achte Sanktionspaket auf den Weg Ziel
Moskau soll sein Öl nur noch zu deutlich
niedrigeren Preisen verkaufen Putin
steht jedenfalls unter wachsendem Druck
setzt aber weiter auf Angriff Lena
sünderbruch
sieben Monate nach Kriegsbeginn und
zusammen mit der Krim kontrolliert
Russland nun etwa ein Sechstel des
ukrainischen Staatsgebiets Präsident
Putin vollendet formal die
völkerrechtswidrige Annexion der Gebiete
luhansk Donetzk saporegja und herrson
diese Worte aus dem Kreml klingen
deshalb zynisch
wir machen keinen Unterschied zwischen
Russen und Ukrainern das haben wir nie
getan und werden es auch nicht tun aber
wenn wir unseren eigenen Weg gehen und
ich glaube dass dieser Weg schöpferisch
ist werden wir ohne jeden Zweifel alles
abschneiden was uns daran hindert
voranzukommen
ganz anders und ungewöhnlich offen
äußert sich der Vorsitzende des
russischen Verteidigungsausschusses im
messenger-dienst telegram die Armee
müsse mit dem Lügen über den
Militäreinsatz aufhören
wie Russland in den zwangsweise
eingegliederten Gebieten die Grenzen
ziehen will ist unklar denn Moskau
beherrscht aktuell nur Teile dieser
Regionen hier orange
die ukrainische Armee hat laut Präsident
selensky mittlerweile dutzende
Ortschaften zurückerobert
unsere Kämpfer hören nicht auf und es
ist nur eine Frage der Zeit bis wir die
Besatzer aus unserem ganzen Land
vertrieben haben alle russischen
Beschlüsse alle Verträge mit denen sie
versuchen sich unseres Landes zu
bemächtigen all das ist wertlos
ukrainische Einheiten sind auch in
Luciani eingerückt ein strategisch
wichtiges Dorf am Fluss nipro von dort
ist ein Vorstoß auf die von Russland
besetzte Hafenstadt herson am Schwarzen
Meer möglich und wahrscheinlich
Russlands Antwort auf die ukrainischen
Erfolge Drohnenangriffe nahe Kiew dort
wächst auch die Sorge vor einem
möglichen russischen Einsatz nuklearer
Waffen in der Hauptstadt haben sie die
Reserven an Jodtabletten aufgestockt und
auch die Evakuierungspläne sind
geschmiedet
wir sprechen jetzt mit für in Moskau und
Kathrin Eigendorf in Kiew zunächst zu
dir Kathrin gekämpft wird vor allem im
Osten und Süden wie ist denn die
Situation jetzt in Kiew
also in Kiew war es ja sehr lange
ziemlich ruhig und schien der Krieg sehr
weit entfernt aber während die Regierung
im Moment die Siege im Osten der Ukraine
feiert und zunehmend selbstbewusst
auftritt erlebe ich die Bürger hier
zunehmend verunsichert also die letzten
Nachrichten darüber dass möglicherweise
Russland hier taktische Atomwaffen
einsetzen will die Situation auch um das
Atomkraftwerk SAP Parisi die danach wie
vor sehr unsicher ist
versetzt die Leute hier in große Sorge
wir haben es ja gerade schon im Beitrag
gehört zunehmend kaufen Leute hier
Jodtabletten es ist keine Panik aber es
ist doch im Prinzip eine weitere
Eskalation wird hier von den Leuten
befürchtet von vielen Bürgern und was
man auch mit großer Sorge sieht ist die
Situation an der belarussischen Grenze
und die Möglichkeit das Putin wieder
Truppen Richtung Kiew schicken könnte
und auch die Hauptstadt wieder stärker
ins v von Angriffen nehmen könnte das
ist hier eine sehr konkrete sorge dann
blicken wir auf die andere Seite gehen
weiter nach Moskau zu für begaben für
wie geht der Kreml mit den jüngsten
militärischen Niederlagen um
ja kremmelchef Putin der gibt sich
betont gelassen und er sagte heute dass
man die Situation in den annektierten
Gebieten stabilisieren werde aber Kritik
am russischen Vorgehen des Militärs und
an der Logistik vor allem die macht sich
eben doch breit und sie kommt von
durchaus einflussreichen stimmen hier in
Russland da ist zum einen der Anführer
der Tschetschenen ramsam kadirov oder
auch zum Beispiel der Gründer der
Söldnergruppe Wagner beide fordern
unabhängig voneinander ein härteres
Vorgehen in der Ukraine kadirov zum
Beispiel der denkt schon laut über eben
den Einsatz einer kleineren Nuklearwaffe
nach und prigodien der Chef der
wagnertruppe der wütete dass man die
Verantwortlichen Generäle die er
Volldeppen nennt barfuß und mit
Sturmgewehren die Front schicken sollte
aber bisher ist es eben so dass diese
Kritik auf die Generäle abzielt auf den
Generalstab aber nicht den Präsidenten
selbst erreicht und das obwohl er der
Oberbefehlshaber der russischen Truppen
ist offiziell und auch öffentlich wird
er aber eben bisher nicht kritisiert
vielen Dank nach Moskau und nach Kiew
phöbe und Kathrin ja wie die jüngsten
ukrainischen Geländegewinne zu erklären
sind dazu gleich ein ZDF heute live mit
Ex Nato-General Egon Rams um 19.30 Uhr
in unserer App und auf unseren Social
Media Kanälen
wir schauen auf die britische Insel zum
Parteitag der konservativen Tories nach
Birmingham eigentlich wollte sich die
neue Premierministerin Trust sozusagen
als Margaret Thatcher 2.0 positionieren
aber gerade erst angetreten muss sie
fast schon wieder um ihr Amt fürchten
Hintergrund sind Steuersenkungspläne die
erhebliche Turbulenzen auslösten
inzwischen aber schon wieder vom Tisch
sind mehr von Andreas Stamm
nicht nur die Tür knirscht vor dem
bislang wichtigsten Auftritt in listras
Karriere es kracht im Gebälk ihre Partei
rebelliert die Umfragewerte im Keller
die Wirtschaft in Aufruhr alles wegen
Trust radikal liberaler
Wirtschaftsideologie die sie verteidigt
hohen Steuern und wenig Wachstum wir
schaffen so Wirtschaftswachstum bauen
Großbritannien durch Reformen wieder auf
die letzten Wochen haben gezeigt wie
schwer das wird verwandel bringt nimmt
Erschütterungen in Kauf aber leider
wollen nicht alle den Wandel
auf ihren Wandel Pfeifen Sie hier bei
acmi in Birmingham seit 150 Jahren
Pfeifen für jeden Geschmack nach brexit
und Corona sehnen sie sich nach Ruhe und
Stabilität dann kam der Wachstumsplan
der Premierministerin schlimm weil er
die Inflation anhalte
die neue Regierung hat einen turbulenten
miesenstart hingelegt die Idee dass man
Steuern auf Pump senken kann ist eine
äußerst unkonservative Politik ich bin
schockiert
so wie Partei und Wähler Steuersenkung
für Spitzenverdiener nach einer internen
Rebellion abgesagt mehr für Reiche
mitten in einer Wirtschaftskrise so
wurde trust in Umfragen unbeliebter als
Vorgänger Johnson erst kurz im Amt fehlt
sie noch in der premier-riege des
Fanshops erstmal nicht bestellen so
Parteien Insider ohne radikale
Kursänderung könnte Trust noch vor
Weihnachten Geschichte sein
sie erzählt von neuer Freiheit die das
Potenzial und die Talente der Briten
freisetzt aber alle umfragen sagen dass
nur zehn Prozent der Briten mehr
Freiheit wollen sich unfrei fühlen es
ist die falsche Botschaft die Menschen
wollen Sicherheit
zur falschen Zeit am falschen Ort nur
schnell weg nichts fürchten die
Konservativen mehr als wieder einen
Wechsel an der Spitze doch nach diesem
Parteitag könnte weiter mit Trust ein
noch größeres Übel sein
wir sind in der nobelpreiswoche heute
ist Chemie dran die Forschung der
Gewinner ermöglicht zum Beispiel den
zielgenauen Einsatz von
Krebsmedikamenten drei Wissenschaftler
aus Dänemark und den USA wurden für die
von ihnen begründete Klick Chemie geehrt
Barry Sharpless und Morten meldal hätten
die Methode entwickelt mit der chemische
Bausteine vergleichsweise einfach
miteinander verbunden werden können so
dass Nobelkomitee Caroline bertosi habe
die Klick Chemie dann auf eine neue
Ebene gehoben und sie wird heute
weltweit eingesetzt
mehr als ein Jahr ist die
Flutkatastrophe im Ahrtal mit 134 Toten
her jetzt hat das rheinland-pfälzische
Innenministerium Videos aus der
flutnacht veröffentlicht die neue Fragen
aufwerfen die luftausnahme aus
polizeihubschraubern zeigen Häuser bis
zum Dach unter Wasser und Lichtsignale
von Menschen in wahrscheinlich
verzweifelter not aufgenommen wurden sie
zwischen Schuld und mayschoss aber warum
werden sie es jetzt publik und wurden
die Informationen rechtzeitig
weitergegeben dazu Marion Geiger
die flutnacht im Aartal vom Wasser
eingeschlossen machen Menschen auf sich
aufmerksam Aufnahmen eines
Polizeihubschraubers initiiert vom
Innenministerium die Übertragung der
Bilder schlug damals fehl dann waren sie
14 Monate lang verschwunden
der rheinland-pfälzische Innenminister
Roger Lewins sagt er habe die Bilder
jetzt erst gesehen und darauf sei
Hochwasser zu erkennen aber keine
Flutkatastrophe zu erahnen
auf diesen Film sind keine eingestürzten
Häuser nicht die weggerissenen Brücken
die Bahnlinie die zerstört wurde kein
einschwimmendes Auto ein Tank zu sehen
also nicht das was wir dann im Hellen an
schrecklicher Verwüstung und Verheerung
in diesem Tal feststellen mussten im
Untersuchungsausschuss des Mainzer
Landtags sagte levens aus er habe in der
flutnacht kein belastbares Lagebild
gehabt die Videos sind laut Polizei
jetzt erst gefunden worden das sei
bedauerlich aber die Infos aus den
Videos habe das Innenministerium damals
bekommen aus Sicht der Opposition hat
der Minister jedes Vertrauen verspielt
da stehen Menschen auf den Dächern die
um ihr Leben kämpfen die mit
Taschenlampen um Hilfe nachsuchen und
der Innenminister setzt sich mit zwei
polizeischiffs hin und erklärt er hätte
nichts wissen können im übrigen
instrumentalisiert er damit die Polizei
das ist auch unanständig und wenn er
nicht jetzt endlich merkt dass er
zurückzutreten hat dann ist die
Ministerpräsidentin dann ist vor drei
Jahr gefordert dies zu tun
die Videos zeigen die Situation im
oberen und mittleren artal viele
Menschen starben erst später weiter
flussabwärts eine rechtzeitige Warnung
blieb aus warum die Existenz der Videos
14 Monate lang nicht bekannt war
versucht nun die Staatsanwaltschaft zu
klären
sie wissen seit Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges auf die Ukraine herrscht
weitgehend Eiszeit zwischen Washington
und Moskau bei der Versorgung der
Internationalen Raumstation ISS arbeiten
beide Länder aber weiter zusammen vor
gut einer Stunde ist eine Dragon Rakete
vom Weltraumbahnhof Cape Canaveral in
Florida abgehoben an Bord 2
US-Astronauten ein Japaner und eine
russische Kosmonautin sie sollen fünf
Monate auf der ISS bleiben und
zahlreiche Experimente durchführen
er war Schriftsteller und einer der
wichtigsten Drehbuchautoren der
deutschen Filmgeschichte der Ostberliner
Wolfgang kohlhas ist jetzt im Alter von
91 Jahren gestorben Kohlhase hatte die
Drehbücher für preisgekrönte Filme
geschrieben wie etwa für Sommer vorm
Balkon und solo San mehrfach wurde er
ausgezeichnet Millionen Zuschauer habe
er tief berührt heißt es in einer
Würdigung mit seiner Menschenliebe und
einem besonderen Gespür für Zwischentöne
wir sind jetzt beim Sport Christian
Ottos bei mir Fußball Champions League
und nicht alles lief glatt für die
deutschen das hat ganz aktuell folgen
nun ist es offiziell Bayer Leverkusen
trennt sich von Trainer Gerardo seane
das gab der Verein soeben auf seiner
Webseite bekannt die Erfolglosigkeit des
Bundesliga vorletzten setzte sich auch
in der Königsklasse fort mit 0:2 beim FC
Porto
die Faktenlage erdrückend für den
Schweizer Fußballlehrer nur zwei Siegen
11 Pflichtspielen schon sieben
saison-niederlagen dann nutzt selbst die
Rückendeckung aus dem Team nichts wir
sind weiterhin überzeugt der Trainer hat
eine super connection zu der Mannschaft
und wir wollen gemeinsam aus der
Situation rauskommen
daraus wird nichts mehr auch in Portugal
zu viel Leverkusener Letargie Bayer
blass und führungslos die Gegner
eskortieren statt attackierend sei du
sanusi und Galliano die Torschützen beim
2:0 Sieg des FC Porto
die Verunsicherung der Werkself gerade
zu greifbar in der Bundesliga am Freitag
ein 0:4 bei Bayern München und der
Rückfall auf einen Abstiegsplatz
als Kandidat für eine seouano-nachfolge
gilt der Spanier shabi Alonso
und dessen Verpflichtungen wurde vor
wenigen Minuten auch bestätigt auf
Kursrichtung Achtelfinale bleibt Europa
league-gewinner Eintracht Frankfurt nach
dem 0:0 gegen Tottenham Hotspur
überragend der Auftritt der Bayern die
sich beim 15:0 gegen Viktoria Pilsen gut
in Schwung brachten für den Liga-Gipfel
am Samstag in Dortmund vor ausverkaufte
Kulisse demonstrierte der Rekordmeister
seine Stärke und blieb im 31
Gruppenspiel der Champions League ohne
Niederlage ein Rekord in der
Königsklasse
und alles zum dritten Spieltag auch mit
den heutigen Partien von Leipzig und
Dortmund hier im ZDF Sportstudio Eva
Champions League von 23 Uhr an und in
der ZDF heute App
vier Wochen nach den schlimmen
Ausschreitungen in einiger sogenannter
Kölner Fans beim Europapokal in Nizza
hat die Polizei fünf Verdächtige
festgenommen ihnen wird Land
Friedensbruch und Körperverletzung
vorgeworfen insgesamt wurden Wohnungen
von 16 Verdächtigen durchsucht die alle
als gewalttäter-sport bekannt sein gegen
sie soll ein Stadionverbot durch den
ersten fC Köln verhängt werden
und ein Erfolgserlebnis verbuchten
endlich die deutschen Volleyballerinnen
bei ihrer Weltmeisterschaft in
polnischen Lodge nach vier Niederlagen
nacheinander setzten sich im zweiten
Zwischenrundenspiel gegen Thailand in
3:1-sätzen durch und warten damit ihre
noch minimale Chance auf den Einzug ins
Viertelfinale Ciao vielleicht klappt das
ja mit ein Quäntchen Glück dankeschön
das war der Sport wir hätten jetzt noch
die Zahlen vom Mittwochslotto hier sind
sie 9 10 17 37 38 49 und die Superzahl
lautet 5 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
lotto.zdf.de und auf der ZDF Textseite
ja beim Wetter wenig Änderungen was
nicht das schlechteste ist mehr gleich
von Christa Orban um 21 Uhr gibt es das
heute journal mit Maria das lonka ja das
war die Nachrichtenwelt an diesem
Mittwoch entspannten Abend danke fürs
Interesse und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend immer noch ist diese
langgezogene Hochdruckzone für unser
Wetter bestimmt und bringt uns zum einen
viel Sonne zum anderen morgens auch
Nebel diese Kaltfront die uns jetzt in
der Nacht und morgen überquert die ist
kaum wetterwirksam nur heute in der
ersten Nachthälfte bringt sie im
Nordwesten des Landes hier und da mal
einen Schauer dann kommen die Wolken
Richtung Mitte voran und der Regen wird
weniger sternenkla bleibt es vor allem
im Südosten des Landes hier bildet sich
dann auch Nebel und es ist am kühlsten
mit sechs bis neun Grad morgen früh
ansonsten erreichen wir Temperaturen
zwischen 10 und 14 Grad in der Nacht
morgen liegen die Wolken der Kaltfront
vor allem zwischen Main und Donau der
Nebel löst sich rasch auf es fällt aber
kaum mal ein Tropfen Regen raus das
gleiche gilt für die Wolken hier an den
Küsten bei einem kräftigen westlichen
Wind viel Sonne haben wir aber vor allem
im Westen und im norddeutschen Tiefland
dazu ist es etwas kühler als heute 16 17
Grad in den Mittelgebirgen und an den
Küsten am Bodensee erreichen wir noch
mal 22 Grad am Freitag geht es mit
ruhigem Wetter und einer ähnlichen
Temperaturspanne zum Wochenende wird es
etwas kühler am Samstag im Nordwesten
und im Süden noch etwas wechselhafter
aber dann wird es schon wieder ruhiger
tschüss